[Aplausos]
casi avergonzado mohamed vulgar se asoma
en el balcón del restaurante duro para
recibir el premio con court el
reconocimiento literario francés más
importante por su cuarta novela el
recuerdo más secreto de los hombres
de la academia goncourt envía una señal
muy fuerte creo que a muchas personas en
primer lugar al medio literario francés
por supuesto pero también a todos los
círculos literarios del mundo francófono
azul y medio guitarra de l'espace tronco
zone a sus 31 años el escritor senegalés
es uno de los receptores más jóvenes del
premio y el primero de áfrica
sub-sahariana a través del teléfono su
padre no oculta la emoción
tengo un sentimiento enorme de
satisfacción y orgullo y todo lo que
puedas imaginar para describir una
dedicación extrema
la obra narra la fascinación de un joven
escritor por una novela africana de
ficción publicada en la década de 1930 y
el efímero ascenso de su autor acusado
de plagio antes de hundirse en el olvido
una historia polifónica donde se mezclan
los géneros homenaje al poder de la
creación literaria que buscar nunca deja
de cuestionar los la literatura
y creo que la literatura es un acertijo
y una pregunta que el deseo de escribir
es un acertijo y una pregunta hay
escritores que saben desde temprano por
qué quieren convertirse en escritores y
que saben exactamente cuándo se
convertirán en escritores no sé cuando
quise convertirme en escritor ni
siquiera estoy seguro todavía
el joven recibirá un cheque de diez
euros como premio y la promesa de miles
de ventas por su trabajo